we're gonna begin with this Attorney
General William bar will face some very
tough new questions today about his
response to the mother report at a
Senate hearing it's going to take place
in just a few hours Judiciary Committee
members want to know why Special Counsel
Robert mother told the Attorney General
that he was frustrated with bars
original summary of that report in a
letter Muller told Barr his message to
Congress quote did not fully capture the
context nature and substance of Muller's
views on obstruction of justice the
Justice Department says that Mahler also
said quote nothing in the Attorney
General's March 24th letter was he
inaccurate or misleading Paula Reid is
at the White House Paula good morning
good morning John the Attorney General
previously told lawmakers he didn't know
if the special counsel agreed with his
conclusion on obstruction but CBS News
has learned that not only did the
Special Counsel send far a letter
the two men longtime friends and
colleagues spoke on the phone and during
this conversation Muller encouraged the
Attorney General to release additional
information that the Attorney General
would only commit to releasing a TRADOC
did report as soon as possible the
evidence developed by the special
counsel is not sufficient to establish
that the president committed an
obstruction of justice offense Attorney
General William Bar has publicly
defended his decision not to charge the
president with obstruction of justice
but according to a letter first reported
by The Washington Post Special Counsel
Robert Muller complained to the Attorney
General about how bars for page summary
to Congress did not capture the full
context of his work Muller wrote to Barr
there is now public confusion about
critical aspects of the results of our
investigation this threatens to
undermine a central purpose for which
the department appointed the special
counsel to assure full public confidence
in the outcome of the investigations in
the letter Muller also requested that
Barr released the reports introductions
and executive summaries to the public
according to the Justice Department
after receiving the letter bar called
Muller his longtime friend and colleague
the Attorney General expressed that he
did not want to release the
in piecemeal fashion the two men agreed
to get the full report out with
necessary redactions as soon as possible
the Attorney General accurately
characterized your positions on
conspiracy and obstruction sir we still
haven't heard from Muller directly and
it would take the Justice Department
more than three weeks to release the
redacted report during that time the
president used Bars memo to characterize
the report's findings thankfully there
was no collusion and there was no
obstruction completed its report and
found no collusion and no obstruction
almost two weeks after his call with
Muller Farr denied knowing where the
special counsel stood on his
characterization of the investigations
findings support your conclusion I don't
know whether Bob Mahler supported my
conclusion CBS News has obtained a copy
of bars prepared remarks for today's
hearing in these he makes no mention of
the phone call or the letter but it does
make a point to say that no one at the
Department of Justice ever overruled the
Special Counsel on any proposed action
he also uses these remarks as an
opportunity to double down on his
decision not to charge the president
with obstruction of justice even though
the special counsel presented evidence
on both sides of that question and could
not reach a conclusion but this is just
the script and as we've seen that this
is an attorney general with a tendency
to go off-script
Margaret Paul up thank you